luna the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin if
you're just getting into crypto it's the perfect
place to start hey guys and welcome back to the
lehigh pen show powered by icon plus capital the
vc firm sponsored by block fi and luno so block
five if you don't know they do some really really
cool interest rates so i've left a link somewhere
and everywhere it's in the description it's in
the title whatever so yeah check them out
joining me today um is a very good friend of
mine somebody who um has actually helped me a lot
in the space so when i first got into the space
um he was very very kind and helped show me the
ropes and all that stuff um he's had some amazing
success in um this current bull market if we're
still in a bull market i think we are um so i
can't wait to delve in and learn more about it it
is of course the lycon guy john kim what's up john
what's up how are you i am perfect because i'm
on the layout mama i made it i'm only leia show
so before we went live i told john that
um this was not going to be inappropriate
everything is going to be professional and it's
going to be it's going to be very good it's going
to be very educational because i have a lot of
questions okay okay and like i said you were one
of the people that were so kind to me um when
i first started growing on twitter and you know
you helped me a lot you helped me with my podcast
um so many different things but you have a pretty
interesting story yourself um and i don't know a
lot about it and i don't think a lot of people do
so i want to go into it because you're not
actually you weren't actually born in america is
that correct you were born in south korea that's
correct so tell me about this when did you so
tell me about this because obviously you're very
like american through and through but i feel like
you've kind of gone through the american dream
but i want to go back a little bit you moved
your family moved when you were younger from south
korea what happened yeah so my my dad uh decided
that the only way that we can succeed is for him
to take us to the united states because we were so
poor like like really poor where you put like
these charcoals underneath the floor to heat
heat the floor and we had this small hut and all
of us slept together in a row and you have to walk
in the dark to go to the restroom in the
restroom there's just a hole in this whole
bunch of maggots and stuff so every night if
i had to go to a restroom i'd just cry walking
over there because i didn't want to be around
so he left one year earlier he came to arkansas
at a chicken ranch uh with work visa and
then a year later um he invited us over
got his green card and then we came and then we
lived in texas in a government government housing
apartment and that's when i learned english real
quick because everybody kept messing with me
um back then you know asian people got made fun
of a lot because we're so different you know
so uh i i learned uh cuss words real quick because
i had to fight a lot to to protect myself so
yeah that's insane i actually didn't know
that you were that poor in south korea
very poor they're like if i think about
it i remember when i was younger my dream
my as a kid my dream was to sleep on
a bed one time before i before i uh
die that that's how simple yeah that's how simple
my dream was and i remember one of my birthdays
when i was like six uh five or six my dad brought
one banana because my dream was to eat a banana
and then he brought two gave me one by myself for
my birthday and gave one for my sisters to share
i remember i ate mine i took it and they were
beating me and i ate the second one because
um i really really wanted a banana i really
wanted to use my favorite food in the world
so when i came to america my dad had a basket
full of bananas at our apartment i haven't really
liked banana ever since too many memories too many
memories no because i ate so much of it because i
thought and then i got sick of it so now i'm like
when i look at a banana i'm not i don't really
so how old were you when you came seven seven
and do you remember it vividly was it strange
did you leave loads of friends behind or were
you just happy to come leia when i got my
dad had this old lincoln continental like
this long car like a used long car when i when
i when i got out of the airplane and i saw him
saw the car saw the apartment saw the bed i
literally thought i was in heaven like i i
said we made it we made it and then later i found
that we were living in a government apartment so
it wasn't that great but compared to what i when
i came from it was unbelievably uh luxurious yeah
so do you ever think what your life would
have been like if you if your dad didn't make
the decision just to take you all and go yeah i
would have died because uh when i came here in uh
fifth grade i i i had leukemia so i had medicaid
and and the us us you know texas paid for a lot
of the stuff where i got into remission but if i
was in korea i would i would have died because um
there is no aid if you don't have money
you're not you're not getting treated you know
so so you were sick when you made the move or bef
or once you'd arrived uh about three four years
after i arrived yeah your story is so insane why
do you never i don't hear you speak about it much
i do i do sometimes when somebody gets it out of
me but it's nothing that i want to voluntarily
tell people it's kind of you know it's nothing
too cool but yeah it's fascinating because no
no listen it's fascinating because um you made
some really interesting remarks during the whole
um presidential campaign and you know about um
it's a very divided time right and you made a
lot of interesting remarks so america gave you a
lot so you must um have an interesting perspective
on people who americans who hate america because
you've got a lot of those you know and they say i
get it i i get where they're coming from it's very
emotional and you know uh the media everything is
hyping it up and sensationalism and everything but
i come from a country to where um like i always
say this united states is my stepfather south
korea is my father but my stepfather raised me
and gave me opportunities that my father would
never have given me so if korea south korea and
the united states went to war i would fight for
the united states that's how much i appreciate
because um i would have been dead i wouldn't be
here if it wasn't for the american way american
dream and american system so that's why i was
kind of very passionate about people who are
talking about this country as you know
like inherently racist or whatever i'm like
listen there's racism in every country but this
is the only country you can come with nothing
and literally become everything you know so i'm
very patriotic in that way but i just decided you
know i got suspended on twitter for for having
an opinion wait wait what happened go back i
actually never asked you about that why were you
suspended on twitter because i talked about vaxx
how it should be uh a freedom right to take it
or not take it and then i got a little political
and they didn't like it so but you know it's all
good it's all good maybe i just needed a fresh
start so my second account is that what 13 000 but
um it's yeah guys follow follow john kim let's get
him back up to 30k get him even further than 30k
100 we have to do that um so so i want to know so
you you moved obviously to the states and you're
living in government housing where where did it go
from there because now you have a lambo so so
you see the jump it's quite it's quite a jump
so i want to just understand how did you get into
crypto because you you were involved obviously
quite early what were the stages in your early
career like what were you doing before crypto
um so so you know i we came here we're all
my dad worked all the time worked two jobs uh
as a janitor uh my mom worked as a janitor and
then my dad did siding on the side so he was just
always gone so um when i was like uh 17 i hurt my
leg i made varsity football and uh i hurt my leg
and i couldn't play anymore so i quit school and i
started to go into life of fighting and crying so
um but in 2009 uh 2008 everything changed my son
was born 2007. i just felt like i i really needed
to change my life i felt this responsibility
i felt a love that i've never felt before um i
remember when my son was born and i looked at him
and i said dude i don't even know you you haven't
done anything for me but why do i feel like i can
lay down my life for you what love what kind of
feeling is this what kind of love is this that
i'm feeling and that literally changed the way
i saw the world and then um 2000 2009 i started
homeless ministry i wanted to give back to society
so i lived in a homeless shelter for two months
just to see how it feels not that i needed to uh
and and i remember the cool story is when i when
i walked into the homeless shelter to stay there
because i i wanted to lead by example i wanted
to tell people that i know how it feels right
there was bed bugs and like pea stains
all over the small mattress and uh i
remember like for a week just kept biting
now itching whatever after a week the bucks
me and me and the bucks became cool they
stopped biting me and it was comfortable
you know so um i did that for three years i
started i pitched the tent in downtown dallas
and i fed one homeless person and it grew
to feeding a thousand homeless person a week
um it was my full-time job i didn't get paid i
didn't get donations that's why i'm so adamant
about not not getting paid or or getting donations
on crypto because i've done it for three years
and i i left i didn't make any money but i left
the legacy that there you can help people without
taking stuff from them you know so um i did
that for three years and then um i took one
of the homeless person inside my home gave him
a job and everything and he ended up robbing me
and i realized that badly or just robbed the whole
house you know and left but but what can they
do right like that's all they know so i and we
became cool afterwards i forgave him it's all good
and then after that i realized you know like so
99 of the homeless people are setting their ways
because they're older they're like 30 35 40 50.
and i said you know what i think i've done my part
i need to graduate this this homeless ministry
and then later on i really wanted to help young
children because i feel like young children you
can actually change the trajectory of their lives
so um and then i went to business so in
2012 i got into business and in five years
i opened 15 businesses sleeping four hours a
day because i had no high school diploma i had
i had no money i borrowed ten thousand dollars
from my dad and then i opened 15 businesses so
what were the businesses it was cell phone stores
and pre-paid cell phone stores it was led lighting
general contracting interior design you told
me this i remember so i mean you know that's
why i'm so i really want um underdogs to win you
know because i i everybody told me you don't have
a husband you don't have this you don't have that
but then i spoke at johns hopkins i spoke at u-pen
and i just want people to know like no nobody
in this world is going to give me a restriction
right nobody's going to tell me i overcame
death i overcame chemotherapy as a child
right losing all my hair getting picked on i
overcame that i overcame gang life i overcame
counting in jail multiple times you
know so um i just i just want when i die
i want people to know see me as a person that
that inspires them to be able to do whatever
the heck they want if they can imagine it
and if this is the most important part um
if you're an underdog and you don't have that
much to offer you must work two times harder right
that's why i only slept four four hours a day
for like five years to achieve what i achieved so
um don't think that your success is gonna come
just by declaring it just just know you're gonna
have to be willing to suffer more than anyone
else around you then your story will become great
so what would you say the most important
thing out of all of that you've learned
other than you know working hard and not
expecting everything just to come to you
but would you say the most important thing
is that you learnt being that you still
wait that you still apply today sorry yeah
so being brutally honest with yourself
when i wake up in the morning i look at myself
and i you know it i'm brutally honest with myself
and when you do that your ego gets crushed your
pride gets crushed and then you you realize that
you still need to make improvements and you still
need to try to become a better person um so i
think so many people are blinded by their um by
who they are and they look out and judge everyone
else for me as soon as i start judging somebody i
look within because maybe i'm projecting something
that i'm not seeing so when you do that people
around you will love you people around you won't
like wants to be around you because you're
not some egotistical like prideful maniac
that is always trying to say the last word and
always trying to you know take the spotlight so um
yeah i think brutally being honest with yourself
and crazy work ethic which starts in the gym
like i fight i fight weights in the gym
every day and i win so when it comes to life
it's not that hard like if i can
kill it in the gym i come out
i can kill it in life too so self-discipline being
brutally honest and work ethic like no one else
and work ethic does not come overnight guys it
comes years and years of really like pushing and
pushing and pushing until it becomes and one of my
coaches told me this and it was such a great line
it says amateurs do it until they become good
professionals do it until it becomes automatic
you know what i mean so i feel like my
life right now is all an automatic mode
because i've been doing it for so long so yeah
that's amazing i think everything that you've
done is so commendable um and i wish you talk
about it more because it's such a fascinating we
never see that side of you we always see like the
jokes and the laughs but you know i want to see i
want to see the other side um so how then did you
hear about crypto your son was born that was
2008 i think he said same time yeah sorry
so how did you hear about crypto 2017 like it
was early like january or something um i was keep
hearing about bitcoin then i came home and my ex
my wife at the time she said i said hey have you
heard of bitcoin he said have you heard aetherium
and we're like you know why don't we just kind of
dabble into this and then uh i remember wait but
how did you hear about it though like why did you
just on the internet just like i don't know
it wasn't from anyone's particular i just
kept hearing about it you know so i remember
i went to a t-mobile prepaid t-mobile store
and i bought my first bitcoin at 800 through
liberty x or something like i gave them cash
i had to sit there and wait until they sent it
to my wallet and i was like this is so scary
i'm literally giving them like cash and
i'm getting this digital money that i
completely do not understand so uh and my wife
i think at the time bought ethereum at like
ten dollars or five dollars but we
trust me we sold it all you sold it all
i mean because back then there was no thing i
didn't know what haul meant all i know is like oh
this thing went up a little bit less sell you know
so later i learned that having diamond hands is
is something that you acquire over a long period
of time so yeah but you're known as the litecoin
guy right do you still work with charlie lee 100
i'm litecoin first always will be amp is my second
baby that's gonna take litecoin to the masses
uh but here's how i came across like one yeah
um i was trading at the time right i was trading
stocks at the time and then i got into crypto and
i started trading i started day trading thinking
i was a genius because i i mean i was killing it
um but as i was trying to move bitcoin through
exchanges and you guys don't know this like
this is before binance like when binance first
came like i was going back and forth and i sent
bitcoin and i'm sitting there like oh my god i'm
losing so much trade because this dang thing will
not confirm you know wait what were you trading
on what how are you sending coinbase like btc
finance like i was just going through all these
exchanges and every time i send bitcoin i would
just lose lose so much on the trade but then i
found litecoin it's like boom i was like oh man
i love litecoin because this is the
perfect coin to move between exchanges
and then i started doing my research and then
i really realized that uh litecoin is that coin
that not only could it be a store value but
a good means of exchange and um you know
satoshi nakamoto is not here right so
there's a lot of battles to be fought between
the the huddlers the miners and and the developers
and i just felt like charlie lee being alive um
could give litecoin a better direction faster
until it became uh robust and and where the
litecoin didn't need him anymore so um yeah
that's that's how i fell in love with liquid
and you put a lot of money into litecoin didn't
you like you went all in in 2017 yeah 2018
yeah august 6 2018 i sold everything uh
i saw my house and then gave the proceeds
the house proceeds to my ex at the time and
i said you gotta let me do this i cannot
do anything else right now because i'm so
passionate about you know spreading the
gospel of litecoin and and getting people into
the space before it's too late and then i sold
everything and then i left in my litecoin truck
and then i started to live a life of digital nomad
so wait to to put all that so to put everything
that you own after the main ball run like after
big one hits 20k to put it all into litecoin
you got to have some serious conviction so
i'd love to understand where that conviction
came from so the conviction came from this okay
um this is one of the uh revelation or or or
understanding that i feel like i got from from the
upper skies or something i started for some weird
reason i fell in love with a calculator because i
suck at like i'm the only asian dude in the world
okay that sucks at math okay everyone who copied
me in high school failed right i'm not i am no
charlie um i started playing with calculator
and i started to crunch numbers about how i could
put a million dollars in my hands with my business
and i realized i just don't have enough time to
literally like even if i took a job every day the
like led lighting business whatever i just like
the numbers don't add up i cannot retire you know
and i was like okay there's got to be a better way
and i realized this we are living a addition plus
life and i needed to be on a multiplication life
in order for me to retire and succeed and i looked
and i and i looked at all my businesses and i
looked at everything that i was doing i said john
the race has started way before you even if
you and and i like experientially right i only
slept four hours and even when i ran that hard i
could not even catch up because the game was so
far beyond me right i could be a good middle
class and make a little money and have a house and
live with this life but to make it to be
able to retire i was like i need to live
the multiplication life and the game has started
way before me and i looked at bitcoin litecoin
and cryptocurrency i was like you know what
the starting line is not that far like there's
some ogs that left in 2011 2010 whatever but i'm
like i 2017 i could still see the starting line
this is the only chance i have in my life to be
able to change the trajectory of my financial life
and with my work ethic be able to catch up to
them because if i'm willing to sleep four hours
then i better see some some kind of uh progress
right yeah so um i went from life of addition
to life of multiplication and i knew this was my
chance it would never come again in my lifetime
so i went all in on that multiplication life which
was cryptocurrency yeah that is literally how i
feel right now um i i've never heard it put in
that's in that way i think that's great um you
know looking at it as an addition like versus a
multiplication like you think that's a great way
to look at it um because it's true you're not
gonna you're not gonna retire nicely on your
nine to five um some people say they've done it
don't believe it till i see it um i've seen the
opposite i've seen the absolute opposite i've
seen people give their life to the man and then
you know the game the game is designed for you
to stay an employee stay in middle class the
game is designed to be that and cryptocurrency
takes that game turns it upside down and gives
a a normal person a chance to reach
for the stars and actually reach it
so you went all in 2018 um so fast forward wait
wait not yet wait i don't fast forward to the
to the bull market yeah i want to what was it
like in that period because there was a period of
time where things were just down it was down for
like three and a half years um and that's hard i
remember you you were sleeping in different places
you didn't have like you said you're doing the
digital nomad lifestyle but it was difficult so
tell me about that journey through those few years
i mean it was it was difficult but it wasn't
impossible right like i i like difficult i mean
i being in a gym everything that hurts that is
difficult that you don't want to do is probably
the one thing that you need to do to like gain
muscle and to go over overcome so i already have
that mentality to where but when litecoin hit 22 i
was like damn i'm broke i am i was not interested
did you invest in wait what price did you
invest in my first one was like i think 10 bucks
right 10 8 or 10 bucks and then i i bought all the
way to 350. like so i'm telling people like we've
all been there we've all bought high you know but
um i stopped trading when i when i got on the road
and i remember just sleeping in roche motels and
and like my truck and i had a i had a membership
a lifetime so i would go into a 24-hour lifetime
and sleep on the sofa and stuff like that and my
friends the lycom community would let me sleep
in their couches but um i remember when it when
my portfolio just dropped 90 something percent
and i said to myself um this is not hard enough
because i still yeah because i knew that i still
had an option to go back to where my ex-wife was
and to stay there and have a place to stay and i
was like no this is not bad enough it needs to be
worse because the story that i'm creating cannot
this can't be this is not bad enough and so when
it really hit the worst was um like march when
colgate happened you know that's when uh i i hit
rock bottom in my relationship everything just
like and i was stuck in dallas in a small room
um with my mom yeah and with a broken rib and
covet and and i said okay okay god this is it
the this is the bottom we're going up from here i
remember saying that to myself because i've never
been in a situation where i've really felt
like there's no option you know and that's what
everything i had i think i had the best year in
2020 so all went up from there that's unbelievable
i remember that because that's when you and i had
met yeah um sorry i remember that really well so
yeah so you know litecoin like everything else
started to go up how was it um you know charlie
like i i'm so grateful for charlie lee because not
only was he a good friend to me but he was he was
uh my mentor uh he was my friend um he helped
me one of the story like um people don't know is
when i was broke and my mom didn't
have a place to stay um charlie
he sent me some money to take
care of her mom you know so um
oh wow yeah so that's amazing
yeah so for me um crypto
i'm sorry i didn't mean to i just i was so curious
i didn't mean to no it's cool so it's not it's not
it's not about money and if you ask the close
people around me i never did it for money
is money important yeah but i i went out because i
wanted to prove the world wrong you know that's my
number one thing and then along the way you know
people like charlotte like really helped me so
um i'm i'm very loyal to the people that that like
help me without asking for anything in return so
um yeah that's why i'm still uh litecoin
number one all the way until it hits
four digits i i'm not gonna stop um
promoting it and and talking about it
yeah it's really no not your bad
no it's really interesting and i
appreciate sharing it because um you know it
really is all about the community i'm sorry
it is all about the community um you know you
really do find like-minded people who really
have a bigger vision and have a greater
vision for the world and want to make
um you know make the world a better place and
help everyone who you know who's part of that
so i had no idea that about charlie lee so that's
really cool that you said he helps he helps a lot
of people behind the scenes and does not ever
take credit or does not ever talk about it so
that's why i'm just saying you know there's a
lot of dark people in this space that tries to
scam people um charlie is one of the most ethical
morally upright person i've ever met in my life
and that's why i'm i'm so bullish on litecoin
because it's doing everything right the right
way you know so yeah yeah i feel like i need to
buy a bag of litecoin now i have a little bit
i feel like i need to buy more i feel i feel
like i do so so what happened so so right so
the market started to go up things started to do
better and you obviously suddenly were in a much
better position things became a lot more
positive so at what point in 2020 did you
look at your portfolio and you were like this is
it like the hard the hardship is over i've made it
um i think uh towards like september okay
september 2020. i knew i knew i made it
and and and like i told people but people don't
know this uh i made my friend 12 like i think
upwards of 10 million dollars and then um i didn't
want anything you know um but my friend bought me
the lamborghini as a gift for uh you know so i
thought that was a cool story um it is i don't i
would never be able to buy a lamborghini i i just
don't have it in me to to purchase something that
expensive but to get it as a gift um it was it was
it was tremendous for me and then to be able to
convince the dealer to accept litecoin so as so it
was 884 litecoin for that lamborghini and um and
another cool thing is my friend told me this
he said uh i want you to enjoy the hell out
of it you can't sell it you gotta ride it until
the wheels fall off or upgrade it take care of
your children give them a good time so my my son
came to field trip to the mall next to my house
in plano and it was two two school bus full of
kids came here for a field trip i remember that
day i pulled up in my lamborghini with the top
down and it was a tremendous experience for my son
and i took him out to the back in a parking lot
and let him drive the lamborghini as a 14 year old
so yeah so it was a great experience all
around how you can use a car like a supercar
to raise your sons like you know make him look
good and allow him to enjoy it so yeah it's i
think my story is that not not i didn't make
great investments or i was a great trader but
i've helped enough people to where they they gave
me back some of the things and do you remember how
um i helped a ufc fighter recover a wallet and i
told him no you you're my icon his name is chelsea
and i say dude you're my hero i used to watch you
on pay-per-view and then after we recovered it uh
you know he sent me half of what was in there
so so the story so what i'm trying to say is
like i never asked for money but for some reason
the universe found a way to reward me somehow
and i and i can't i'm not trying to spiritualize
that no you can spiritualize it okay yeah
so i just felt like my my whole journey wasn't
about me buying and selling and hobbling
it was about me doing everything that i
believe was the right thing to do and i was
my conviction stood firm even if i didn't have
money even if i went broke i did not cross that
line and ask people for money whatever which
i could have and when i did that the universe
and the people around me rewarded me up with was
a lot of money now you know because at that time
it wasn't that much money but now if you think
about it yeah you know so it pays to be a good
person i think that's amazing you know people are
always so cynical about life and people are always
so negative um and so jaded as well i remember you
were quite jaded at one point you were just like
no leia if you haven't seen the world the way i've
seen the world and i'm just there all like bright
and positive and you're just like you haven't seen
what i've seen um but it's nicer but it's nice to
see you know like the the other side of that
so you're staying in a really cool place right
now tell me about it oh yeah this is a high-rise
resort style 24-hour concierge free valet parking
awesome cool awesome conference rooms i
don't know it's just last year i i remember
i did a live stream and i said uh um next
year i'm gonna live in a high rise and i'm
gonna have a lambo and i declared it and
for some reason i wanted to keep my word
and so i i live in this awesome place and i have
a lamborghini um it's just um i just you know
leia i just maybe it's the chip on my shoulder
maybe it's just the way i grew up you know but
like i don't pursue money but i i what i what i
would die for is to prove to the world that that
that i'm right that if i do it in a certain way
that i can succeed because 99 of the people in
this world are following money are doing like all
these stuff to make money right and i just felt i
just wanted to show the world that if you have
a conviction if you if you're set in your ways
and you and you and you do what's right and you
add value to people without asking anything back
that you can succeed and i truly believe
leia like even when we first met i was like
leah this is what i do if you want to start a
podcast here everything this is this is what i
100 this is what it is and and you were like john
thank you i'm like leia i don't want anything from
me i just want you to freaking kill this game and
and i called it i said you are the next big thing
i did didn't i and i said i'm not a big the only
yeah going i was gonna make a stupid joke yeah go
on when we first met how many followers you have
like eleven thousand fifteen thousand or something
you're like a hundred thirty three thousand so oh
yeah today yeah no so i feel i feel good and and
and you know the people who receiving it know too
when you help somebody without expecting anything
in return the person receiving it can receive
with a smile and they're they're very glad right
but once you have that look where oh you better
pay me back or something that's when things get
kind of kind of weird so yeah i think that's
that's what i'm the most proud of that i did
not waver i did not uh take the shortcut and
and and i made it this way yeah i feel like um
because so i'm kind of like you in some sense
in that you know you like to do the right thing
you like to the right wing you like to be a
good person but i often feel that we saw we
so you said like you have this chip on your
shoulder because you have to prove that the
world is a certain way but you don't think maybe
you have to prove it is that way because like
it would be too um it would be too hard to believe
that there is a world where you can succeed by
being bad and selfish and evil it would be too
hard to accept that there there's a world like
that which i think there is it's true it's it's i
mean mostly it's like that you know so i mean even
when i was doing the homeless mission everybody
told me to ask for donations from church and
ask for personal donations i was like no no i will
feed thousand people without donations it will
happen and then i went to donut stores on sunday
and got the leftover donuts went to walmart asked
for the leftover chickens like it it worked out it
worked out you know so so now everything's worked
out you've got your nice lambo you've got your
high-rise your valet parking and all that all the
fun stuff what what's going on now like what what
is day-to-day um i i i don't have anything to do
like my only responsibility in life right now is
um responsibility is my live stream my podcast
jason and ben on tuesdays that's the only
thing that i'm um see this is what i think
retirement is retirement is you don't have to
be anywhere anytime because of someone you know
you can do whatever you want anytime anywhere so
right now i just work out a lot and i'm building
up my body and my health and just kind of relaxing
um because i ran so hard for four years i wanted
one year just to be able to do what i want and
then maybe if i catch another bug next year but
i'm not going back on my word guys we are going to
10x this year from january so that's that's so so
so wait so okay so just yeah let's just get your
thoughts on the bull market so what is going on
we obviously had that major major dump yesterday
ten thousand dollars unbelievable on the day that
el salvador recognized baker's legal tender pulls
back by ten thousand dollars something funny there
yeah um so so what are your predictions for the
rest of this year do you think this is just uh
a healthy pullback taking us on to new highs
in a few weeks few months well you know last
year i think it was october when uh me jessica
and ben we're live and i told ben um bitcoin's
gonna hit 35k before the end of year and he said
how's that gonna happen in like a matter of weeks
i'm like just watch i was i was i was late by five
days right then and i told people that lycone was
gonna hit uh all-time high 360 uh in april um i
was off uh it hit uh five days later it was in may
um so what i'm saying is bitcoin i'm always
right what i'm saying is i'm always right
no no i'm not saying that's to say i'm always
right i'm not emotional if i said something i'm
going to stick with it whether the market's up
down fun is whatever so i call 250k bitcoin this
year blow off top litecoin will be above four
digits and you know amp will be above 75 cents
and i'm i'm sticking to that and i'm i'm rarely
wrong when i when i feel this gut conviction in
my in my in my gut so um so this is just the
beginning even for you i just want to tell you
we have just started right we have just started
in this crypto game and if you have over a hundred
thousand dollars in this game right now you're
you're going to be a multi-millionaire in the next
two three years and i mean you'll be a millionaire
this year but you'll be a multi-multi-millionaire
in the next four years and and because a wise
man once told me uh bitcoin litecoin 10 x's every
four years because it's written in the code it's
true it's written in the code that's brilliant no
it's so it's so interesting i i hope you're right
um you know i wanna um i i do agree with you i
think right now is just the land of opportunity
so much opportunity just to build some serious
serious wealth uh don't hope hopeless for the
week believe i called i called you okay i said
you're the next big thing okay you 10x in
your follower account so why can't bitcoin 10x
come on come on it's true okay so all right fine
so just finally then like what advice would what
advice would you give me i'm coming to the states
you know i'm coming what advice would you give me
number one be careful because you ain't ugly
okay you gotta be careful i'm ugly if you get
on the wrong side of me so just listen if you're
ugly you can go down the dark alleyway all day
long nobody gonna mess with you okay so number
one be careful and have fun and and you know
you know lately zooby came to
united states and he did so
much he he affected so many lives and i just hope
that you coming to america uh you will change
a lot of people's perspectives and minds and
like bless and inspire many people and at one
point i'm gonna come see you wherever
you are miami austin dallas el salvador
i may come see you and be your bodyguard we'll do
it we'll do it john i want to thank you so much
it's been such a pleasure and i appreciate
you being so open and honest because i had
so many questions i wanted to know more about
the guy behind all the jokes and the litecoin
thank you leia i appreciate it hey everyone thanks
for tuning in guys don't forget to follow john on
twitter and don't forget to tune in next week
for another episode alright we'll see you then